Usa el método de completar el cuadrado para encontrar el valor de "c" que convierte la expresión
"x" cuadrada -44x más "c" en un trinomio cuadrado perfecto.
Después describe la expresión como un binomio al cuadrado. Lo primero que quiero hacer es escribir otra vez esta expresión aquí abajo,
para que no se me olvide y vea qué es lo que tengo que hacer.
"x" cuadrada -44x más "c" y esto tiene que ser un trinomio cuadrado perfecto,
y ¿Recuerdan que es un trinomio cuadrado perfecto?.
Pues es aquel que se puede factorizar en un binomio al cuadrado perfecto y ¿Cómo se ve un binomio cuadrado perfecto?.
Supongamos "x" más "a" al cuadrado que al final pues es lo mismo que "x" más "a" por "x" más "a" y bueno pues vamos a multiplicar.
Cuánto es "x" más "a" por "x" más "x", "x" por x" ,"x" cuadrada
"x" por "a" ax, "a" por "x" pues también es ax y "a" por "a" me da "a" cuadrada
y esto se puede reducir un poco. Esto es lo mismo que "x" cuadrada más 2 veces ax,
aquí hay una "x" y aquí también hay una "x" estos se reducen a 2 veces ax
más el cuadrado del segundo, es decir el cuadrado de "a" y entonces este resultado es justo mi trinomio cuadrado perfecto.
Y si te das cuenta aquí la izquierda ya tengo "x" cuadrada y después tengo un
-44 que multiplica a "x", lo cual tendría que ser 2a y "c" por lo tanto tendría que ser igual a
"a" cuadrada. A ver vamos a escribirlo
-44 es lo que está al lado de la "x", es decir si quisiéramos que fuera un trinomio cuadrado perfecto
-44 tendría que ser igual a 2a y entonces "c" tiene que ser "a" cuadrada, es el término que no tiene que ver con "x"
"c" es igual "a" cuadrada ¡Muy bien! Y como sé cuánto vale "a" pues yo tengo que
-44 es igual a 2a ¿Qué les parece si divido todo entre 2? Esto entre 2 y esto entre 2,
2 entre 2 se van y entonces me queda que -22 es igual a "a".
Dicho de otra manera "a" es igual a -22 y ¡Perfecto! Ya tengo el valor de "a si "a" vale - 22
entonces -44x es 2 veces el primero por segundo y por lo tanto
esto se empieza a parecer cada vez más a un binomio al cuadrado perfecto.
Ahora lo que me falta saber es cuánto vale "c" o dicho de otra manera ¿Cuánto es el cuadrado de "a"?.
"c" es igual a "a" cuadrada que es lo mismo que -22 al cuadrado y cuánto es -22 por -22.
A ver 22 por 22 bueno al final recuerden que menos por menos me da más por lo tanto no es necesario poner el signo.
2 por 2 son 4, 2 por 2 son 4 y después pongo un 0, 2 por 2 son 4 2 por 2 son 4
y me queda 4, 8, 4
484 el cuadrado de -22 es lo mismo que
484 por lo tanto, si quisiera que esta expresión fuera un trinomio al cuadrado perfecto, se tendría que ver así "x" cuadrada -44x más 484
y entonces ya lo podríamos factorizar en un binomio al cuadrado perfecto, por que esto es
"x" cuadrada -2 veces el primero por el segundo, es más déjenme ponerlo así "x" elevada al cuadrado,
más 2 veces el segundo que es -22 por "x" más el cuadrado del segundo, es decir el cuadrado de -22
y como está pasando esto ya lo puedo escribir como un binomio al cuadrado perfecto, por que usando lo que está escrito a la derecha,
esto me queda como "x" -22 que multiplica a "x" -22 o dicho de otra manera esto es lo mismo que
"x" - 22 elevado al cuadrado. Todas estas son expresiones equivalentes.